I'm not, you know, heard anythin
Well, I'm hardly.
I'm okay because I'm still alive
I'm grateful to be alive
and grateful to me and my family
You know,
they bring in a peep out of my h
We hear you, old buddy.
We just got grabbed the kids
and got him a kid's iCloud.
I'm glad we didn't go
in the hallway, cause
because their highway is destroy
everything is caved in. The dog.
And when we open a bag, no dog,
and we ain't got no tornado.
But take the dog.
The trailer
sitting over there
and the world is like all this s
you see over here. Out is rubbis
A stray trailer.
Just everything to try to see it
What you just heard,
that was just one family's accou
of some very scary moments
after a deadly tornado barreled
northern Louisiana.
Officials outside
Shreveport say that one child wa
and the mother is missing
after the twister struck Kato Pa
And at least 20 people were inju
when the tornado ripped through
home park in Farmersville
and that's where we find CNN's
meteorologist Derek
Van Dam for CNN this morning
with the very latest on that.
Derek, so much devastation
just before the holidays.
What are you witnessing
what are you seeing there on the
Yeah.
Don, it's
heartbreaking considering that i
right before the holidays
and that this particular communi
in northern Louisiana
took what appears to be a direct
Of course,
we are still in the shroud of da
so we'll be revealing a lot more
the sun comes up.
But just hearing that sound bite
from the one of the survivors
a moment ago, it's
incredible to to think
that someone can survive
what I am about to show you.
So I'm going to try and tie this
for you.
But you're looking at
the piece of a roof.
You know,
we've seen a lot of the tornado
that moves through Caddo Parish.
We're in Union Parish as we spea
But those are the tornadoes.
When it makes contact with the g
it literally takes that vortex
kind of spinning off
anything in its path,
including roofs of houses.
And and we've seen, you know, de
from tornadoes before.
But what is likely the top of th
I just showed
you came from the building
that's directly behind me here.
And this is part of the Union
Villa apartment complex.
This is actually the office
for the apartment complex.
Now, the apartment complex
that you cannot see
over my left shoulder here,
we're actually blocked
by a heavy police presence
within this area
was completely flattened.
And the devastation
there is is catastrophic.
And just hearing some reports
from the local sheriffs within t
there were 20 to 25 injuries,
some critically injured as well.
And when you're talking
about taking buildings
and wiping them off of their fou
it's a miracle
that anybody would be able
to survive something like this D
All right.
A deadly
and destructive
tornado tore through northern Lo
last night.
Officials
outside of Shreveport
say one child was killed.
That child's mother is still mis
this morning after the tornado s
Caddo Parish.
At least 20 people were injured
when the tornado
moved through a mobile park,
mobile home park in Farmersville
We got
in the
shower, like I said,
and then all of a sudden, by the
we got hunkered down here, it wa
The roof was gone.
And, you know,
they always say that you're trai
Well, this was a big trying to c
through here.
CNN meteorologist Derek Van Dam
live this morning.
And when you joined us
at the beginning of the program,
the sun was not up. Now it is.
And you see a whole lot more.
Yeah.
Poppy,
we are seeing some of this devas
and simply heartbreak in damage
that was left behind
by these devastating tornadoes h
in northern Louisiana.
You're just seeing
really a small drop in the bucke
because we are still not permitt
to go to the mobile home park
that was directly hit behind me
But we're in Union Parish.
This is just northwest of Monroe
Louisiana, and you can see
just some of the memories left
over of children's toys,
typical shrapnel,
the tops of roofs
and buildings, electrical wires
you name it.
This is what
we would typically see
within a devastating tornado.
But what you're not seeing behin
because of our restrictions
within this particular area
is the impacted mobile home comm
that's behind me.
And we talked to an eyewitness
who gave us some firsthand accou
They came across some individual
this morning who literally were
walking out of the woods,
talking about how their
their mobile home
was swept into the woods
and just being completely disori
after this tornado struck just m
after that particular
devastating and terrifying
thing for them to to take place.
There are cadaver dogs
and search and rescue operations
that are still ongoing
here, as is typical
with any kind of
tornado damage
that we would see across the cou
But the National Weather
Service is en route
to come here
and assess how much
how powerful
the winds were
in this Union Parish tornado
that has left the path of destru
that you see directly behind me,
Derek Van Dam, thank you for bei
We're thinking of everyone
there, of course, this morning.